bonjour à tous comment vous allez bien
j'espère parce que moi ça va plutôt bien
il fait plutôt beau il fait plutôt froid
et on est à l'automne je vous ai fait
une vision un peu complet des choses
alors aujourd'hui c'est une vidéo un peu
particulière parce que ali express math
challenger disons main sur un gros
monsieur gros monsieur monsieur greu on
voudrait que tu fasses une sélection sur
notre site de deux produits qui
t'intéresse dans un budget restreint
budget restreint pourquoi pour les fêtes
de fin d'année pour qu' on puisse en
tout cas nous soit s'acheter des choses
soit acheter les cadeaux à les tarifs
super intéressant des bons produits
qu'on va retrouver directement sur un
l'express donc j'ai un budget entre 50 à
peu près 100 euros à peu près et vous
avez sélectionné deux produits
alors pour refaire un tour un peu
compliqué joue longtemps allié exprès je
pense que vous connaissez c'est un des
sites il commerçants les plus grands au
monde vous et pour trouver plein plein
de choses je vous passe extrêmement
rapidement l'électroménager automoto de
la beauté et du bien-être des vêtements
du bricolage et ça c'est bien mais moi
ce qui m'intéresse c'est la tête je vous
ai donc sélectionné deux produits le
tout premier c'est celui là c'est une
montre la tarifs
il est entre 120 33 121,33 à 124,90 est
c'est extrêmement précis comme tarifs et
vous avez des tarifs à partir du 11
novembre à 9h à un peu moins de 100
euros donc si vous intéresse je vous
aime tous les liens en bas dans la
description c'est le premier produit on
va se le déballer ensemble on va le
regarder
et puis le deuxième produit j'ai
sélectionné et c'est celui-là c'est un
smartphone du midi humide et jc une
marque dont je vous ai déjà parlé un
smartphone qu'on peut trouver aux
alentours de 104 à 124,80 pour être
extrêmement précis et voulait par trois
à partir du 11 novembre 9h entre 83 99 à
100,80 et l'idée dans tout ça c'est de
pouvoir faire des cadeaux de nous ou
alors pouvoir carrément vous faire
plaisir avec des produits de bonne
qualité avec des marques sont connus
reconnus âme à ce titre je sais pas si
vous connaissez mais c'est des
fabricants de montres connectés moi
j'aime beaucoup les produits à ma suite
et humide j une fois de plus vous en ai
déjà parlé alors on va commencer par la
montre moi je ne l'est pas encore
ouvertes du tout et autant vous dire que
je voulais garder la surprise avec vous
hop
moi j'aime bien les montres connectés à
leur mort est effectivement là vous la
voyez comme ça mais en réalité elle est
pas comme ça alors effectivement là elle
n'est pas à lui mais pas du tout en fait
ce que vous voyez là
et bien c'est pour vous montrer ce que
pouvait faire recette manque là elle un
truc qui est vachement intéressant c'est
que vous avez des widgets que vous
pouvez venir personnalisé en gros votre
nom à l'intérieur qu'est ce que je vais
avoir tout mon câble pour venir le
recharger c'est magnétique donc j'ai le
positionnent comme ça et ça se charge
donc ça c'est bien ici en plus vous avez
une batterie de 220 millions paire eur
j'ai coupé des minutes le temps de faire
des mises à jour donc là tout est ok la
montre et un jour le gps et un jour les
polices sont à jour le fia boire est un
jour tout est à jouer alors cette mental
est cool vous avez un seul bouton sur le
côté ici là ici ce qui est cool c'est
vous prévenir personnalisé alors voulait
s'est appuyé sur le dessus et vous avez
sur le petit bouton en bas ça sorte que
je trouve vraiment intéressant vous avez
plusieurs cadres le cadre de envoyez la
météo une météo centre et trois petits
rumba par exemple sur vidéo je vais
m'appuyer dessus météo jeu rapide si je
peux venir changer
je pense ici à l'humidité les uv lever
coucher du soleil la météo en fait je
vais vraiment paramétrer choisir ce que
je veux ce que je m'affiche et donc ça
c'est plutôt bien
alors voilà je veux l'humidité sur celui
du bager la météo j'ai rappelle
d'événements pas à chaque heure
fréquence cardiaque toute la journée ou
alors la météo alors la main ici la
météo je vous cache pas que ça me va
bien et je trouve ça assez pratique en
bas ensuite sur les 3 calories fréquence
cardiaque batterie souvenirs les
personnaliser par exemple batterie j'ai
depuis je perds un compteur de pages par
la température l'humidité les uv
je peux avoir la sédentarité je bouge
bouge pas le sport le chronomètre
je peux avoir la musique compte à
rebours à malvesi pas mal de choses je
vous ça plutôt bien allez on va pas se
mettre les calories j'ai déjà là bas on
va se mettre à les affaires quand elle
avait gelé déjà la batterie ça m'irait
bien
et après j'ai accès alors à l'état
savoir si je bouge je bouge pas ma
fréquence cardiaque mon sport j'ai
différentes activités course marge vélo
compagnie bon je vous passionne à 12 ans
tous donc ça c'est plutôt bien
les activités la météo la musique
notification les alarmes rappelle
d'événements plus et puissent tous mes
petits paramètres et ensuite ans que je
suis sur l'écran d'accueil à des jeux
sur le côté je me ferais quand ce cas là
je n'ai pas au poignet donc je ne vois
pas ma fréquence cardiaque non recevoir
ma fréquence cardiaque
je vais avoir mon nombre de pas et puis
je reviens ici vous avez un écran amoled
ici pouvait venir modifier la luminosité
de l'écran en automatique ou alors venir
carrément hop la booster si vous le
souhaitez donc vous ne réglez vraiment
comme vous voulez vous avez ici un écran
de 348 pixels par 442 à 341 pixels par
pouce d'un écran de 1,65 pousse ses deux
lames oled vous avez un verre corning
gorilla glass 3 pour venir le protéger
c'est plutôt bien elle est résistante
jusqu'à 5 atm 14 jours d'autonomie cadre
en métal
elle tourne se ramasse fit os bon moi la
mode je trouve plutôt bien surtout un
tarif qui est très bas donc ça c'est
bien donc ans et est le premier produit
le deuxième produit il se trouve ici
hop là je vous en ai tout ça c'est un
smartphone de la marque u midi j alors
remis 10 gige j'en ai déjà parlé il ya
très longtemps
dimanche j'en ai pas parlé ici c'est le
à cette pro vous avez un peu les
informations techniques derrière mais on
va se les passent et extrêmement
rapidement
tac 5 ce hayon welcome j'aime bien que
tu aurais avec des petits messages comme
ça c'est toujours sympa tu vas voir les
informations essentielles sur son
smartphone on a un écran de 6,3 pouces
full hd qu'un ratio de 19 points 5/9
temps d'écran ltps on a une caméra de
celle fille de 16 mégapixels on a un
processeur c'est un ailier au p 23 oct
accord 4 gigas de ram 64 go de stockage
c'est la rpd dire 4 x on a une batterie
de 4 950 millions père heures avec de
l'usb c'est pour mieux la recharge est
on un double coeur de carte sim plus une
carte micro sd pour augmenter le
stockage et on est sur un android
stockent donc 100% android haut niveau
l'expérience donc ça c'est bien regardé
samedi à ce qu'ils sont bien antérieures
link the world plutôt pas mal brooke et
on ça marche il ya un bien d'un mal est
dans petit lettre j'aime bien les
petites lettres tomber des petites
lettres moi comme ça ça me plaît
toujours
petite tête avec la notice à l'intérieur
sur ce smartphone
ok bon c'est assez efficace c'est quoi
ça on a une coque de protection qui avec
ça c'est pas mal
caméra de 5 mégapixels ici c'est pour la
macro j'ai une caméra de 16 mégapixels
qui va être mon ultra grand angle avec
un champ de vision de 120° jugnauth
caméra de 5 mégapixels c'est ma caméra
principale qui ouvre à f 1.8 et ici j'ai
une caméra pour la profondeur de 5
mégapixels mais bouton de volume que je
retrouve ici le smartphone vient de
s'allumer le bouton pour la guinée peut
atteindre le capteur d'empreintes
digitales je vois bien que j'aie mon
seul up qui est juste là mais des
petites flèches ça s'est assez mal en
fait la part du médecin d'avoir mis ça
comme ça on a un noir un peu brillants
issus envoyer si un smartphone 2018 tous
cas plus classique l on tombe sur un
android dit bon voilà une bien bien un
mot là-dessus vous aider à trouver vos
différents paramètres
3 qu'est ce qu'on va avoir ici fait me
voir notre appareil photo avec les
quatre caméras qui sont situées là bon
forcément l'attaquent on peut activer le
hdr images vidéo portrait mode nuit du
slow motion ok pourquoi pas vous avez
bien évidemment accès à votre place tort
avec tout votre catalogue d'applications
pour venir installer les applications
que vous souhaitez les jeux et compagnie
alors et si on n'est pas sur un
smartphone très haut de gamme
on va venir installer des jeux ne sont
pas forcément des jeux trop gourmand
mais beaucoup de jeu du plestan pour
venir s'amuser pourquoi pas enfin vous
le voyez vous avez un smartphone qui
coûte à peu près 100 euros ou peut
trouver un tarif vraiment intéressant
ils ont présenté deux produits vous
pouvez venir vous procurer directement
chez hays express atari vraiment très
intéressant si ça vous botte
je vous ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description je crois que là j'ai relevé
le challenge de hay express a trouvé
deux produits aux alentours de 100 euros
il ya beaucoup de produits sur alix
prête pour ma part un challenge relevé
allez jeter un petit coup d'oeil à plein
de produits vous pour être livrés
rapidement entre trois et quatre jours
il y en a pour tout le monde à tous les
prix et ça c'est cool et même vous pour
votre challenge de fin d'année pour
faire des cadeaux à petits prix ou à
grand prix vous pourrez y trouver votre
compte sur ce j'espère que ces deux
produits vos intérêts quitte moi ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaires
entre le midi gilles à cette pro et
entre
la masse fit la gts la montre que les
tms fit pas ce que vous en pensez en
barrant commentaires quand on se trouve
extrêmement rapidement pour continuer à
parler tech parce que oui oui il ya
plein de choses qui arrivent en cette
fin d'année et ça c'est très cool
prenez soin de vous des gros bisous à
très vite tiens tiens
[Musique]